well Christopher um being a young black
male from the NSA from Newark New Jersey
I remember you know hearing about the
incident on Facebook and watching the
video and being very moved you know
emotionally
it definitely hit home I felt like it
could have been me and I'm watching the
videos over and over and over again
trying to find a reason for for it to
happen like what it Oscar deserved in
that moment so you treated the way he
did and murdered and couldn't really
find what I was looking for an outlet to
kind of express myself so you know four
years later when opportunity came along
for me to play Oscar Grant the third I
jumped at it and I felt like it was a I
felt response but certain sense of
responsibility to play the role so
I have so many and like influencers you
know in my life in my career um in the
early stages you know people like David
Simon Peter Berg ages Elva being out of
the Cabrio
Ben Affleck Paul Giamatti Joseph
gordon-levitt Denzel Washington
Will Smith the list goes on you know
between actor and producer and both
sides of the camera you know definitely
inspires me
I want to actor and I want to produce on
the right I want to create so there's so
many different inspirations that
especially music to definitely it plays
a big role in um you know my motivation
and what fight you know keeps me going
you want a creative side so it's a whole
bunch of different things one tool that
I think I use sometimes when I get lost
on any days on the back of my sides I'll
write like a journal you know what that
character does when he first wakes up in
the morning and I would write out up
until that point and it's like it up
into that scene that I'm getting ready
to shoot so it just gives you a back
story gives you a little lead-in to the
character you know so say that you know
if the scene started off at you know you
know first period in you know and
you know in high school first period
whatever in English class you know I
would write how I woke up this morning
you know what I ate the interaction I
had with my family what kind of mood I
was in that I finished my homework that
night cetera et cetera leading up to
going into class and it just kind of
gives you a little warm-up into like you
know what you're walking into
almost event or run the other way no
just joking uh any advice I would I
would I would definitely explain all the
lows you know all the the downside of
acting and being an entertainment
industry before I would encourage
anybody to know to try to pursue it just
so you know exactly what you're getting
yourself into a lot of people see you
know the the glitter and the gold and
the tension and the limelight and all
the accolades that you get from you know
being an actor or actress but um you
know it's really good you know what you
get yourself into it's um it's a lot ups
and downs and you got to be prepared for
that you know and and after knowing all
the you know the downside you know and
you still want to move forward and still
think of something for you then I would
you know full-fledged
say continue follow your dream don't let
anybody tell you know let anybody you
know defer you you know in either
direction if you think you're doing what
you're supposed to do and continue to
work hard you know I think do your
homework you know if you go to bed at
night know and you work harder than
everybody else then you know that's
something that you can hang your hat on
at the end of the day